I don't really have any appreciable
amount of carbohydrates until the
evening so I'm typically in a state of
fatty acid oxidation or you know mild
ketosis most of the day and you know
unless you're like a to a day
hard-charging athlete there's no need
for like two big carbohydrate boluses
during the day unless you got a
maximized glycogen restoration after an
early day hard workout and with that
strategy I avoid a lot of glycemic
variability like a lot of glucose
fluctuations during the day I find out
have more stable energy levels in
cognitive levels because our dinnertime
is usually like a big family dinner or
social time or going out to a restaurant
with friends or whatever I want to be
able to for the more social meal
actually indulge a little bit I save all
my carbohydrates for the end of the day
yeah and the release of serotonin in
response to the carbohydrate feeding
which enhances your melatonin release at
night so you sleep better too so I just
think as long as you pay attention to
the rules this whole idea of carb
backloading is actually a pretty good
strategy
then Greenfield in the building how are
you man
good not in the building I'm actually
outside and some farm Road that by my
house but but yeah I I could only stay
in a building for so long the sun's
sun's out today got a nice cool cool
wind whipping up over the plane so I
apologize if it sounds occasion like I'm
in a hurricane but uh but yeah we'll
call it a building God's God's giant
building outside that is where you are
man so getting a little bit of walking
in keeping yourself moving in these
times ah you know I walk a lot every day
anyways any excuse I can get the walk I
just love to love the move and get some
sunshine and yeah you know I spend a lot
of time these days you know doing
consults and calls sometimes indoors or
you know doing a lot of writing and so
if I can get outside I'll do it I like
it man we are not using the c-word today
the c-word is not being included in this
podcast we are we are talking about some
evergreen stuff your new book boundless
might actually be useful if people are
in lockdown because it is one of the
heaviest books I've ever felt in my life
so much throw some blood flow
restriction bands on it start to do some
overhead presses that boy well you could
use it as a step to reach high objects
if you need it as well you know so today
I want to go through three main areas I
want to talk about your morning routine
I want to talk about you set up for
working I don't want to talk about your
sleep and your nighttime routine so okay
start enough what does your current
morning routine look like I want the
full monty but for Monty
all right well interrupt me if i tender
right hold too much no but I yeah I
usually you know wake up without an
alarm unless I got to catch a flight or
something like that I just find I
naturally tend to wake sometime around
like it's just like 5:45 6:15 somewhere
in there and I just find that that yeah
waking naturally I'm not opposed to some
of these devices you know like I I sleep
on one of these chilly pad things that
keeps your body cool or you're asleep
which is great for enhancing your deep
sleep and there's apparently a function
on it where you can activate it to
circulate more warm
water to gradually wake you I don't use
that function I'm nervous I might just
pee my pants when that warm water turns
on and then I have one of those sunrise
alarm clocks for when I do got to set
the alarm on but just kind of gradually
bleed Sun into your room so you wake a
lot more slowly which i think is just
wonderful for not you know ripping you
out of a deep sleep cycle if you happen
to be one in one in the in the morning
and so yeah I wake I roll over and I do
some gratitude journaling for the first
few minutes of the day I write down one
thing I'm grateful for I write down a
one person who I can help that day
whether it's like you know calling my
mom or or you know helping the neighbor
move something or or even just like you
know giving a bottle of wine to somebody
who I know might need a smile that day
and you know I just really like that
others facing type of mentality to start
today because I figure if I you know if
I'm writing down one person I can help
each day that's 365 you know good things
I might do during the course of a year
so I do that and then I write down also
any any insights that I had from my my
dream cycles earlier in the night or you
know any just little encouraging words
to myself that I I don't want to act on
during the day and then I get out of bed
I'm kind of into into the the Ayurvedic
concepts in terms of the morning routine
so I do a quick tongue scrape which
takes just a few seconds with a little
copper tongue scraper what's the logic
behind that back of the tongue to the
front of the tongue just helps to put to
clean out some bacteria in the mouth
that accumulates during a night of sleep
and then I also do oil pulling so I use
coconut oil blended with some essential
oils like clove and peppermint and swish
that around in the mouth well I'm tuned
around during the day you know taking a
pee and getting things ready for the day
and that's also a really really great
oral hygiene tactic again barred from
Ayurvedic medicine and so I then go
downstairs into the kitchen and if I've
woken pretty early or if I have been
traveling a lot and I'm trying to kind
of like reset my circadian rhythm
to whatever time zone that I happen to
be in I'll usually wear those blue light
blocking glasses that people wear at
night
I'll wear those in the morning because I
find that that reddish orange lens kind
of does a good job simulating sunrise so
if I'm flipping on lights in the kitchen
or glancing at my phone or open to the
computer anything it's a little bit more
of a gentle way to wake up kind of that
same concept of not waking with an alarm
clock wearing these blue light blocking
glasses in the morning kind of gives you
that really kind of sunrise desk feel in
the morning because my lazy ass is not
gonna be out of bed in the sun's rising
so what's the what's the brand of
sunrise glasses you use I use the ones
made by raw optics you know the the
owner of that company Matt maruka he's a
friend of mine he's just he's so steeped
in light research and he's constantly
retooling the lenses to block out
specific wavelengths of light and a lot
of these blue light blocking companies
they know how to make a quick buck and
although import cheap lenses from you
know India or China or whatever and then
mark up the price it's all on Amazon and
he's actually doing a really good job
with his lens technology and so I I used
the wrong optics brand there's a few of
the good ones out there I think what's
the company I'm blanking on their name
blue blue blockers I think they do a
pretty good job and there's a there's a
couple others out there but I use the
raw true dark true dark isn't does a
good job so use these these raw red
lenses and usually I'll take them off
typically after I've been up for about
20 30 minutes or so so again I'm just
kind of easing easing from a light
standpoint my body into the day and then
once I've spat out that coconut oil I
kind of rinse my mouth out because you
don't want to swallow it because it's
just like it's accumulating bacteria and
stuff in your mouth so it's it's it's
just like cleaning you want to spit it
out so I split out in the trash can so I
don't clog the toilets with oil I
learned that lesson the hard way don't
spit in a toilet or a sink it clogs the
plumbing so you actually spit your oil
into trashcan rinse out your mouth then
I have a big glass mason jar full of
goodies so I I make myself a big glass
mason jar with some hydrogen tablets in
it because hydrogen there's a lot of
good research from the molecular
hydrogen
nation on the on hydrogen for
anti-inflammatory and selective
antioxidant properties and the you know
I'm convinced by the research enough to
do a big glass mason jar that at both
the beginning and the end of the day but
at the beginning of the day I put
minerals into that so typically like a
pinch of a really good salt like Celtic
salt or another one I've been using of
late are these these minerals that are
harvested from these algae blooms and
it's it's got like 80 plus minerals and
it's called Kington qu int o n it's like
a like a hypertonic plasma so I put some
of that in the water along with the
hydrogen and then I do two-to-one ratio
of vitamin C and baking soda there's a
really great book that delves into all
the science of vitamin C and baking soda
called forbidden healing and I was I was
so convinced to have to reading that
book about some of the effects on
everything from from a mild change in pH
to an increase in in some immune factor
compounds to just just the overall
physiological effect of both vitamin C
and baking soda thought I just have
right there in the pantry bulk ascorbic
acid and uh and then just Arm and Hammer
baking soda which is naturally aluminum
free and so I got baking soda
I got vitamin C I got hydrogen water I
got minerals all in this big glass mason
jar of water yeah and I just sucked that
down that's kind of my tonic and
sometimes we'll throw a little apple
cider vinegar in there as well
because that is a really nice insulin
sensitizing in fact at the beginning of
the day and lens even more alkalinity to
the drink so so I have that and then I I
put on a pot of hot water or I start the
coffee and I'll go back and forth some
mornings I do coffee and then just
because I don't want my adenosine
receptors to to get too too insensitive
right yeah which makes me sleep till
later on the day I don't do coffee every
day because I don't want to I don't want
to to to create a scenario in which I'm
insensitive to adenosine later on in the
day and can't fall asleep because even
if even if you metabolize caffeine
really well if you're a fast car
the oxidizer and even if you you're not
having a cup of coffee afternoon just
frequent regular use of coffee without
breaks builds up so much of these
identity and received ruse it just gets
harder and harder as months go on to
fall asleep at night yeah so so what I
do is I'll either do coffee or the other
one that I'll do is is cacao T which is
lowering coffee or lowering caffeine but
it has like theobromine and some
dopamine precursors and it has this real
good kind of pick me up feel good effect
nice some people like your of amante for
that but your Bonacci makes me a little
jittery and I like the way cacao makes
me feel instead so I'll typically blend
that with chaga which is which is
wonderful it's it's it's chock full of
melanin chaga is which can actually
interact with sunlight to to kick off
electrons and produce some free ATP so
any photons of light will interact with
things like melon in chlorophyll would
be another example methylene blue which
is marketed now at nootropic that's
another example but because I tell you
in a second I go down to the office and
I do some red light therapy and like I
like getting a little melanin or
chlorophyll or methylene blue in my
system before I go do the red light
therapy and blending this chaga with
some cacao or doing the coffee but that
chocolate uh cacao is really great if
you're doing like red light therapy in
the morning just prime there that
Prime's you for that red light right
just before we move on the yeah you
basically produce an extra ATP you were
talking about ways to assure that your
adenosine receptors don't get down
regulated by spacing your coffee use
what have you found to be an optimal way
to pulse that every other day three
times a week twice a week
what well in the book I talked about how
one tactic for people who just want to
drink coffee every morning you just do
coffee for three weeks and then twist to
a really switch to a good decaf like
Swiss what a process decaf or co2
extraction decaf for about a week takes
around six to eight days to reset those
adenosine receptors but if I'm just kind
of doing it naturally I just listen to
my body basically if I wake up and I
don't feel a need for little extra
caffeine I just don't have coffee
I did the chaga so it typically comes
out to about of two or three mornings of
the week is the chaga and the cacao
the other mornings it's just a good cup
of organic coffee cut you just just
organic black coffee I don't do any
calories just because I don't want to
take myself out of fasted State in the
morning so no no MCT oil or butter or
anything like that just just black
coffee and then on well well the hot
water is going for the cacao tea or the
chaga or the coffee's brewing I spend 10
to 15 minutes just doing body work like
foam rolling sometimes it's like the
little vibrating balls sometimes
lacrosse balls but I just I take 10-15
minutes every morning do deep tissue
work so whether or not I get a massage I
try to get a massage once a week because
I don't you know I figured by the end of
the week I'm getting a good 75 to 90
minutes of really good deep tissue work
and I just find it Prime's my body for
the day a lot of times I combined it
with some breath work a little bit of
inversion so I'll hang from an inversion
table or from some from like some
gravity boots but it's kind of like my
non-negotiable me time for like 15
minutes in the morning I'll usually
listen to like a sermon or a really good
spiritual podcast while I'm doing that
just to start off my day on a really
positive note and and then once I've
done all that I'll grab the coffee or
the tea and I'll head down to my office
and I'll generally spend about a half
hour going through typically like
research articles science some of the
feeds that I follow in in you know like
like health exercise science nutrition
science you know some some different
Twitter feeds and research journals I
just really like to learn at the
beginning the day I find my body just
soaks up and feels really primed to
learn so I'm typically not doing emails
or or you know social media and stuff at
that time I just kind of soak up some
knowledge at the beginning of the day
well I'm having my coffee or my tea and
while I'm doing that I use red light
therapy so I've got these big these
juvenal's in my office that I flip on so
as I'm standing there going through all
the research I'm just bathed in red
light I take off all my clothes and I
just do like naked red light therapy
full-body and and that's for like twenty
to thirty minutes it's amazing it nitric
oxide release
it stimulates mitochondrial production
of ATP it's just this this complete
feel-good effect it's and it's also very
similar to out to sunrise again so I'm
getting that big red light dose in the
morning which is great for circadian
rhythm and you know I like my office to
be just like this total Zen den so you
know I've got essential oils kind of
getting diffused into the air I got that
red light therapy I've got a little
grounding mat that I stand on so it's as
though I were outside kind of sucking up
some negative ions from the surface of
the earth same thing from standing in
that my office I get the the same effect
so so that's just kind of my me time in
the morning and I finish up all that and
you'll you'll find if you guys use that
tactic of baking soda with that glass
mason jar after about 45 minutes that
baking soda kicks in and you just go
have this awesome awesome dump so I flip
off the red lights after about a
half-hour and you know I just I could
tell right away you feel the stomach
gurgling Oh Ben it's like all right it's
ready to go and go upstairs and just
have have an amazing amazing amazing
bowel movement and then you know by then
it's hits typically around you know like
7:45 to 8:15 in the morning and I
usually before I jump into the rest of
the day you know and kind of start
working everything or have some
breakfast I like to do some kind of like
a morning some kind of morning protocol
that makes me feel really good I don't
like to hit the weights hard or do like
a big high-intensity interval training
session in the morning so usually for me
it's either a about a 20 or 30 minute
walk in the sunshine or a 20 or 30
minute song session so this would be
after I go to the bathroom yep yep you
know I'll do you like a sauna plus a
cold soak you know 20 or 30 minutes in
the sauna just the deep sweat again I'll
put essential oils in the sauna
sometimes I'll put on like a topical rub
like you these topical muscle creams
that have things like you know cayenne
and menthol and black pepper because you
just sweat buckets I've found if you if
you smear some stuff over your skin yeah
before we get into the sauna I'm using
one called prototype 8x8 EP science
right now I'll just
like smiling on my arms on my legs you
know put some some really good uplifting
essential oils in there like rosemary or
cinnamon or something that's really kind
of like stimulating to the brain to get
me all charged up for the workday and do
the sauna
so I'm sweating really hard then go
don't go jump in the cold pool or take
the cold shower for about three or four
minutes and I'm either doing that or
just like a long walk in the sunshine
and so do all that and then you know I
own a company called kion and we always
have a call every morning at 9:45 so I
gotta be done showered you know ready
for the day you know spend a little time
with the kids and say good morning to
them and hear about how they're gonna
spend their day they're homeschooled so
they're at home with me all day anyway
so I just gotta check in with them make
sure they're all set for the day and
checking with my wife make sure she's
all set for the day and then I just make
myself a a giant superfood smoothie oh
I'm getting ready for that call with my
team and that you know the smoothie just
changes every day but typically it's
things like you know for my base I just
use ice and then I'll put some stevia in
there or some monk fruit in there for a
sweetener and then I just love to toss a
bunch of a bunch of great stuff in there
so for my liquid I'll usually use bone
broth or kefir or sometimes coconut milk
I make my own yogurt at home usually
using coconut milk or goat's milk as a
base so I'll put some yogurt in there
and then typically a few scoops or
something like your greens I'll put some
collagen in there squeeze them a lemon
or some kind of vitamin C in there and
then I I just blend all that up if I
want a little more creaminess I'll put
like half an avocado in there sometimes
for a little bit of extra greens you
know I grow sprouts at home so I'll put
some sprouts in there and then I'll top
it with just a bunch of goodies like
spirulina like after I've blended it
I'll top it with like spirulina coconut
flakes cacao nibs but I blend the
smoothie really thick so I basically
like eat it out of a bowl almost like an
eyeball with all these negative roots
oh yeah it's amazing it's so good it's
like the highlight of my day I'm
thinking about that one doing my son or
my walk I'm already thinking about that
amazing amazing superfood Bowl
gonna make it home and so I typically
I'll eat that while I'm on the call with
my team just chatting with my team you
know hearing about where everybody's
gonna be up to for the day and just
touching base with with the whole squad
because I'm running my company virtually
for the most part because our offices
are in Boulder but I'm up in uh
Washington State and they're down you
know most of my team's is down kind of
around Colorado so I um I do that call
and then after that from about 10:00
until around 2:00 or 2:30 I just you
know no push notifications no no Twitter
no Facebook no social media I just work
like a horse with blinders on for the
next four or five hours you know comment
that deep work concepts you know like
counting Newports book where I'm just
you know whether I'm writing or working
on a book or a series of articles or
shooting videos doing content doing
consults with my clients or people who
have hired me to go over their nutrition
or their workout plans with them or
their you know their lab work their
blood work sometimes you know I advise a
lot of companies in the health and
fitness space so sometimes it's advisory
calls for different businesses you know
ever every day kind of varies but yeah
but for me that kind of like 10:00 to
2:00 or 2:30 slot is just deep work time
just crush the day during that time
hyper productive and I take breaks about
every you know it depends on on this
style of work that new but every 30 to
60 minutes I'll take breaks and you know
do some pull-ups do some kettlebell
swings you know jump up and down that
trampoline I just like to take little
breaks just to keep my body moving
during those those you know four or five
hours of work but uh you know generally
once I've once I finished all that work
I I come up and I again I have a home
office so I'll make myself some lunch
lunch for me is just usually you know
some good greens like some more sprouts
or really nice plate of greens with you
know a big fan of those smashed diet
like sardines mackerel and Cho V herring
or salmon so usually I'll do like some
kind of really good omega-3 rich
Coldwater fish you know some nuts some
avocado you
another cup of bone broth and I just
have they're kind of like breakfast I
have like a superfood kind of salad type
of thing for lunch but with fish in it
superfood not sometimes if we've had
steak or chicken or whatever the night
before or I'll use that as the protein
topper but again I don't I don't really
have any appreciable amount of
carbohydrates until the evening I save
all my carbs until the evening so I'm
typically in a state of fatty acid
oxidation or you know mild ketosis most
of the day and you know unless you're a
hero like a to a day hard-charging
athlete there's no need for like two big
carbohydrate boluses during the day
unless you got a maximize glycogen
restoration after an early day hard
workout so I find because I typically do
my hard work out in like the later
afternoon or early evening as long as
I've had carbohydrates the night before
my glycogen levels are pretty topped off
anyways and with that strategy I avoid a
lot of glycemic variability like a lot
of glucose fluctuations during the day I
find I have more stable energy levels
and cognitive levels and it also allows
me to because our dinnertime is usually
like a big family dinner or social time
or going out to a restaurant with
friends or whatever like I want to I
want to be able to for the more social
meal actually you know indulge a little
bit like have some red wine or some dark
chocolate or some sourdough bread or
some sweet potato fries or whatever so I
save all my carbohydrates for the end of
the day which is also nice because since
I typically am NOT doing my my hard
workout like weights or high-intensity
interval training or anything like that
until the later afternoon into the early
evening that means that I'm very insulin
sensitive after that workout so those
carbohydrates very easily get
partitioned into you know muscle tissue
should liver tissue in the mole into the
right-most yeah yeah so they don't spend
a lot of time in the bloodstream with my
blood sugar spike so it's just it's a
it's a good scenario for me you know
doing the easy workout in the morning or
the easy movement in the morning no
carbs all day and then the hard workout
later on the day then the carbs at night
so I like come off for the people that
are listening I've been a big fan of
carb backloading for a long time and
backloading carbs for me one of the main
reasons that I like it is that it plays
with the sacrifice reward mentality that
you have yeah oh you're like right it
might be nice to feel satiated with some
slightly more starchy food earlier in
the day but as you I can get through I
can get till 2 o'clock right I'll get my
workout in now it's 4 o'clock I'll have
only gonna wait until 5:00 5:30 and then
you've got your nice big starchy meal
you feel nice and full and obviously
you've got this change in insulin
sensitivity
you've got the improved shuttling and
partitioning of nutrients into the
muscles it seems like a real a real kind
of easy hack yeah and the release of
serotonin in response to the
carbohydrate feeding which enhances your
melatonin release at night so you sleep
better too so I just think I think
especially for an act in person or
someone who's working out later on the
day and someone who's willing not to
like shut their face with random snacks
and sugar earlier in the day as long as
you pay attention to the rules you know
there's this whole idea of carb
backloading is actually a pretty pretty
good good strategy so anyway so I
finished lunch and I'm a huge fan of
napping a huge fan of napping so I took
a nap almost every day for like 20 to 45
minutes and I kind of protect that time
quite a bit I tell my team like don't
schedule me any calls from about like
2:30 til 4:00 I just want that time to
to kind of like have that breather in
the middle of the day and so for for me
you know typically after lunch or with
my bone broth at lunch I'll have
something that's kind of relaxing like
right now I like reishi mushroom extract
kind of relaxes me
tones me down in the middle of the day
and just slip away either and and take a
nap in the bedroom or I have one of
these of late what I've been using for
my naps is I have a soft shell
hyperbaric chamber which just
concentrates oxygen so I go in there I'm
under concentrated oxygen flip on the
oxygen mask and I'll put on some really
relaxing beats I like the one I've been
using of late is this this vagal nerve
stimulator an app called new calm and
that thing will just they say based on
the research it will simulate a full
nine
even sleep cycle in 20 minutes Wow I
don't know if that's true but but I can
literally just turn that thing on for 20
minutes and be dead to the world and
feel amazing and sometimes I'll cycle
through it two times so I'm gonna pull
40 minutes and that's my go to the other
one that I like is brain fm that's
another really good app for just kind of
checking away so I put on some good
noise blocking headphones a good sleep
mask
I like the sleep mask called mind fold
it just blocks out all light and I go
dead to the world from like you know
2:30 to 3:15 or so and that nap just
like I have a better workout later on in
the day I'm more present for evening
activities I just like I'm a huge huge
fan of nap so I find I find sometimes
with naps that I can I can suffer with a
little bit of mood change afterward I
wonder if you've ever come up against
that yeah typically I'll take a
stimulant after my nap lately bring you
back round a little bit yeah yeah
sometimes it'll be a touch of coffee
sometimes they'll pop like some nicotine
gum sometimes we use a nootropic like I
like one called qualia mind something
that kind of like picks me up again in
the afternoon so that's maybe that's
what I'm doing wrong I mean it's I think
my ability to go from hyped to chill too
hyped again just my ability to change
that speed to decelerate and then resell
rate is is pretty tough I mean you know
if you know if you're having a
conversation with a client and you're
getting real hyped up they're having a
great day you're having a great day
you're going back with him forward is
that mushroom extract that you mentioned
sufficient to kind of bring you down in
brain FM a couple of our old beats is
that enough to come you take the chip
that the sting out of what you've been
doing yeah that combined with the food
and your stomach from lunch I find just
it works fine and then the other thing
is that you know if you take a nap and
you're putting some kind of stimulant
into your system around 3:15 I typically
don't go to bed till like 10:00 anyways
and I don't find that that interferes
with sleep the only thing I'm careful
with is if it's if it's coffee a little
bit careful with that so if it's coffee
it's like four ounces of coffee friends
like a micro dose of caffeine yeah but
but that's enough to just give me a
little bit of a pick-me-up and kind of
get me going again after the afternoon
nap
and then um just to circle back to your
work schedule at the moment can you just
tell me about your desk set up the
easing at the moment oh yeah
so like I mentioned I have I have one of
those grounding mats so that I'm getting
a little bit of a mild anti-inflammatory
fact that you can get from the negative
ions from the ground and then I've got a
standing desk and and I just have a
hand-cranked desk I think about mines
made by company called rebel desk very
desk does there's really good desks too
and then I've got a treadmill that I can
walk on sometimes one through Falls yeah
I have the trueform treadmill just
because I wanted a manual treadmill that
could keep up with my I've got really
long legs and I also walk pretty fast
and I find a lot of these manual
treadmills for offices they're like too
slow and too short so I like that true
form because it you know double is
workout tool anyway so you're by
treadmill as well good one you can you
know throw down some sprints and
sufficient plus it the curved nature of
the treadmill engages your glutes a
little bit more man Rudo doing sprints
on that thing is miserable the hamstring
and lower just the whole posterior chain
gets alright yeah it's impossible to run
without engaging your posterior chain on
that thing and it's actually hard to
walk so see I got the true form standing
desk grounding mat the red lights I
mentioned but I'm only using those in
the morning there's actually some
evidence that you can you can overdo it
you can create excess reactive oxygen
species if you overdo the red light
therapy so I just do that in the morning
you said about thin then right now
closer like 20 okay even if I'm in the
office you know sipping the coffee doing
the research stuff for 30 minutes I only
leave the red lights on for like 20
minutes and then what else is in my
office I said there's like an essential
oil diffuser in there if I want to kind
of be in a different position than just
standing or walking I've got a I've got
a chair called the saddle chair which
kind of is it legal I've got one by
Sally s al Li yep and then I've also got
a stool that's also in a pelvic shaped
position that one's made bifocal upright
it's called the Mogo
so there's no chair in my office at all
it's either the pelvis stool or the
saddle chair
have you tried that when when standing
have you tried a small step to rest one
foot on in front while you're standing
that's that's been such a game-changer
for me for anyone who's listening that
uses a standing desk buying like a kids
step you know like what a kid would use
to get up to the kitchen counter oh yeah
anything that raises your foot maybe
between half a foot two foot and a half
off the floor and it really does
decompress my back that's made a big
difference
also I wondered have you tried the
rocker boards I have one called the
fluid stance yeah yeah that's like it's
like a balance tool my son that hard to
balance on so I could be like on a phone
call yeah I'm a big fun it's called a
slack walk and it's basically like a
slack line it was developed for balance
training so I haven't my office is one
of those things I could stand on for a
little bit during like a Pomodoro break
yeah yeah but it can double with
something you can put your foot up on -
that's like a mobile miniature slackline
yeah exactly so yeah so you get a little
bit more increased proprioception the
other thing I have relate to the feet is
I always have a couple of golf balls
like right underneath my feet so I'm
always doing some foot rolling well I'm
standing at my desk so just some some
deep tissue therapy for the feet and
that works pretty well I've found as
well I'm not sure if this is the same
for you but sometimes when I'm doing
some work that doesn't involve my hands
having something to just get rid of the
excess energy so I always have a pen in
my fingers and I twirl a pen I tend to
do that under the desk when I'm
podcasting and actually find my ability
to focus on what I'm doing when I have a
small amount of really basic movement
going on elsewhere makes a big
difference oh yeah that's a good idea I
feel like I'm getting a little bit of
that by rolling the golf balls under my
feet but that's a good idea with the pen
or you could use I suppose you could use
like captain Zach rush Andrew said it
came to the idea came from seeing kids
who have a DD and they given playdough
aha to just play with with the hand
while they're in classes so the killer
the kids have this play-doh and what it
allows them to do is just expel the top
end that that excess energy that they've
got they do something with their hands
and it allows them to focus better and I
just I've had pens in my hands through
you know all of university all of school
put a pen back in my hand and I found
that my focus improved unbelievable
that's a that's a great idea I like that
yeah let suppose a rubber band or like
some play-doh
yeah it's a great idea I like that cool
so um yeah so that let me think if
there's anything else in the office
that's interesting I use if I'm working
in there at night same thing up in the
master bedroom the master bathroom like
I'm not a fan of LED lighting because
even like these newer like so called
biological LEDs they all produce like a
like an imperceptible flicker that's a
little bit irritating to the retina and
there's even some evidence that it may
cause a little bit of damage to the rods
and cones and so I use incandescent
lighting incandescent light bulbs
simulate pretty closely the natural
spectrum that you get from the sunlight
and so all the cans in the house have
incandescent light but then I've got a
like a lamp in the office for nighttime
work that's a red incandescent light
bulb and then up in the bedroom and the
master bathroom and my kids bedrooms
it's all red incandescent lighting so it
kind of looks like a nightclub little
bit you when you flip on the lights at
night but there's no blue light it's
amazing so you so you don't disrupt your
circadian rhythm when you're getting
ready for bed at night or you know you
flip on the lights go take a pee at
night or whatever it just keeps things
you know really stable from a circadian
rhythm standpoint it's ridiculous is a
particular brand of bulb or lamp you
just swatting I just grab grab
whatever's on Amazon it's just already
incandescent light they're a little
they're a little bit more power hungry
than LED lighting but it's you know yeah
it's worth it to me the extra whatever
you know twenty thirty bucks and months
from my electrical bill to to go with
incandescent so do you see I using
incandescent lighting and then red
incandescent lighting at night and yeah
those are some of the biggies in the
office
as far as what I have there's always I
got a kettlebell on the floor of the
office you know always so I got a
step-over it's always top of mine so
remember I'm in there you know I'm
always thinking uh yeah throw down some
some kettlebell swings you know we'll
pull up bar in the door of the office I
can hang from every once in a while when
I'm walking in and out you know I got a
little rule I gotta do five pull-ups
every time you build a door yeah it's
such a good hack I've got a I'm
currently opening up my shoulders to do
some mobility for weight lifting and
I've just got so many resistance bands
on the floor it's like if I don't pick
them up to use them I'm going to fall
over them and hurt myself so I might as
well it's the same as you with your
kettlebells it's like oh god I gotta
step over it I might as well use it yeah
yeah my office just literally ship
moving moving during the day yeah and
then I've got you know I pay a lot of
attention to not having a lot of
non-native EMF like Wi-Fi devices
Bluetooth devices you know so
everything's hardwired with ethernet
cable so I just have like cat 7 metal
shoulders Ethernet cable instead of the
Wi-Fi so I'm just plugged directly into
the router and the Wi-Fi is off and then
I've got these because I had a building
biologist come to my home do like a
walkthrough of anything that might be
producing a lot of dirty electricity or
a lot of a lot of EMF and so I put a
dirty electricity filters in the office
too so these just plug into the outlets
and and filter any power surges that
might be occurring and though and then
yet so no Wi-Fi no Bluetooth and these
dirty electricity filters and so I just
feel better when I don't have a lot of
signals bouncing around that's also the
advantage of a manual treadmill is a lot
of people don't realize like treadmills
produce a huge amount of EMF and so if
you can have a manual treadmill instead
of a motorized treadmill in your office
or in your gym I think it's a good idea
from a health standpoint I want you to
touch actually on Bluetooth did I hear
right that you don't wear air pods or
any other Bluetooth headphones because
of the adverse effects of Bluetooth I
notice that you're wearing Wyatt Apple
headphones at them yeah yeah I'll either
use air tube or you know or wire in
versus Bluetooth just because of you
know a few different studies that have
looked at it and like a dark blood blood
field analysis and shown like some some
clumping of some of the cells in
response these Bluetooth signals and and
compared to Wi-Fi or or say like
4G or 5g signal it's it's less of an
issue but I'm you know I'm using a phone
or you know talking on a lot of these
devices so much I just figure you know
there's an extra three or four hours a
day I don't have to have some kind of
non-native you mess up around my head I
just don't so don't you just yeah touch
done you touched on a topic that I know
a lot of people will be interested in
what's your thoughts on 5g at the moment
is there any way that people can protect
themselves as 5g phones get rolled out
like you can go to your settings and
just switch it back to 4G if you want
giorgia 4g has issues as well the
problem is you know and dr. joe mercola
just wrote a great book called EMF thanh
this ain't even about on my podcast is
you know the effects on the calcium
channels of the cell you get a bit you
got a steep calcium influx into the cell
which basically creates in that positive
charge inside the cell when it's
supposed to be in that negative charge
and then you get some amount of DNA and
raveling from from the from the
radiation you know the the non ionizing
radiation and then you know you also get
a little bit of effect in terms of down
regulation what's called your NF kappa-b
pathway which is responsible for
modulating a lot of your inflammatory
process ease so you know the problem is
that went with 5g not a ton of studies
have been done on either its deleterious
impact or the absence thereof so it's
one of those deals where well if no
studies have actually been done showing
its effects on the human body or rolling
it out you know I'd rather wait until we
see the studies so I'm I'm pretty
careful with it as far as what you can
do to protect yourself obviously with 5g
panels being put up everywhere and you
know the fact we can't escape it I would
say the best thing you can do is to
counteract some of that calcium influx
into the cell just make sure you're
supplementing with magnesium you know or
you can eat organic produce that's grown
really mineral rich soil to get your
magnesium but it's tough to get good
organic produce grown in mineral rich
soil these days and I think magnesium is
a good supplement in the evening anyways
for nighttime relaxation so I just take
magnesium every night you know keep your
red blood so magnesium levels topped off
that'll help with the calcium influx and
then for the for the DNA piece the two
things that can really help to repair
the DNA or in easter to ins you know
like resveratrol or or you know
blueberry powder or pterostilbene or
cacao you know any of the things you
might be working into you know like that
superfood smoothie or whatever in the
morning anyways and that really really
works well hand-in-hand with any nad
precursor you know like nmn or NR or
even like nad you know the occasional
nad IV you know like once a month just
to keep your energy levels topped off
nad and sirtuins work hand-in-hand to
help protect the DNA and so that's
that's number two is do magnesium make
sure you keep your statues and your nad
levels topped off and then the third
regarding that inflammatory pathway the
NF kappa-b pathway the best way to kind
of modulate that and keep it active
would be a mild ketosis which we're
getting from that kind of carb
backloading type of approach and then
also exogenous ketones it actually can
really help with that pathway so like
you know using ketone esters or ketone
salts especially if you're traveling you
know airplanes airports hotel rooms
places where you can't turn the Wi-Fi
off or you know you're getting exposed
to a whole bunch of other signals that
might go beyond you know your phone with
on which you might have the Wi-Fi
disabled or on which you might have in
airplane mode you can't control other
people's so when I travel I really step
up my you know my my supplementation
with these ketones and kind of keep my
my ketone bodies even more elevated to
assist with that inflammatory pathway so
that's another good half like things
those are a few things you do to protect
yourself would be magnesium and and then
sirtuins nad precursors and and ketones
so I like you I like it does a Keon do a
ketone esse no we don't we don't but
there's some good ones out there like HP
MN has some good ones of the company
ketone aid they've got some good ones
all right you know I ketones are so
interesting because for me they give me
almost a buzz very similar to what I get
from alcohol probably because of the
something called 1-3 butanediol and in
some of these ketone esters and when I'm
like making cocktails at night a lot of
times I'll do
you know when I normally use gin or
vodka or whatever else you know that
mixing with ice or lemon juice or
bitters I'll just use a little bit of
ketones instead I actually just just
today literally today at Ben Greenfield
fitness calm I published an article and
like how to make amazing cocktails that
don't have alcohol in him but that still
kind of spin some dials in your brain
and have this feel-good effect and
actually ketones are one way you can do
that so it's not even you can use them
as an alcohol substitute i run i run
nightclubs i wonder if i could sell some
ketone cocktails if i could throw some
of those up i wonder how many people you
want to be careful and I should say this
too if you if you mix ketone esters with
alcohol the byproduct is kind of similar
to GHB and so you wouldn't want somebody
like ordering a mocktail and then also
getting a cocktail and winding up just
like face down in their plate so that
would be yeah bad look there'll be about
that okay so one two we are onto the
night time routine
tell us about your nighttime routine
what's it looking like at the moment
yeah so like I mentioned it you know I I
take that nap and then after my nap I do
a lot of my reactive work like emails
social media you know people need to hop
on last-minute phone calls with me all
that [ __ ] that that's kind of like not
necessarily that doesn't fall into the
productive bucket but it's kind of more
reactive yeah like I save all of that
for later on the day you know because
I'd rather strike while the iron is hot
when I have low amounts of
decision-making fatigue or cognitive
fatigue early in the day and do a lot of
my productive work so I wake up from my
nap and typically you know there's
another hour and a half or two of just
you know kind of putting out fires so to
speak right taking care of all the [ __ ]
that would normally distract you earlier
in the day and then once I finish all
that I'll typically jump into a workout
you know and for me I just finished my
my Russian kettlebell rkc cert so for me
for the past few months it's been you
know snatches Turkish get-ups goblet
squats you know usually a lot of
concurrent strength endurance training
so I'm mixing that up with like you know
airdyne Sprint's rowing machine just
just you know a lot of kind of circuit
style work with the kettlebells mm-hmm
and typically it's something like that
since I just finished that syrup last
week I'm kind of getting back into this
basic weightlifting all right push pull
hinge etc so sorry the weight training
or high-intensity interval training in
the in the afternoon or the early
evening typically I'm working out from
about yeah kind of like death 5:30 to
6:30 yes range right around in there I
remember a little while ago you
mentioned that you'd pivoted from
performance to longevity to look
probably about a year and a half ago I
think what's where's your goals at now
definitely want Java D you know cuz for
years I was competing in Ironman
Triathlon and you know racing for Reebok
and Spartan training and and now I just
want to feel good you know I want to be
strong maintain muscle ice you know
still if anybody joins with me in a
workout you know they tell me a pure
masochist but you know even my workouts
an hour nowhere near you know going out
and crushing you know two hours out in
the mountains you know and and you know
or five hours on the bike like you want
to do any of that [ __ ] anymore I'm
working out like forty to sixty minutes
max hey your condition it's done based
on your Instagram at the moment your
condition looks to be even leaner than
you were
looks to be the leanest I think I've
seen you um I'm about 185 pounds around
four or five percent body fat quite
leave and that's quite lean
yeah but I'm naturally lean like my
dad's the same way my dad doesn't even
do much training and he's proud you know
he's 60 something he's probably like
nine percent body fat so wow that's
genetics good genetics I don't really go
out of my way to like stay super lean
but you know my testosterone is fine
like thyroids fine you know so as long
as my endocrine system is working fine
I'm okay with just maintaining where my
body wants to be I don't you know cuz I
I def you know I'm a foodie I eat a lot
of food I punished a lot of ribeye
steaks and lard and ghee and liver and
you know I just my body doesn't hold on
do a lot of fat honestly just it's the
way it goes
so anyways though so on after
after that uh that kind of like early
evening ish workout that finishes up
sometime around 6:30 or so typically
after that I'll make sure there's no
more email fires to put out no work
that's left to be done and then from
about 7:00 7:30 on it's all family time
like we have these wonderful like family
dinners where we play board games and go
over our gratitude journals and sing
songs and and and just just connect as a
family we all typically are gathering
together and making the meal together
and everybody's contributing and cooking
and laughing and playing music and so
from like 7:30 until 9:00 it's just like
full-on family time dinnertime we
finished dinner and then we go play more
music I'll read to the kids or play them
some songs in the guitar you know we
didn't we we don't really go out to
restaurants that much but typically it's
just like SuperDuper focus and relaxed
and fun family time although all the way
up until after 9:00 and then typically
by about 9:30 or so you know the kids
are tucked away and then my wind down
routine in addition to those red lights
would be you know as we're making that
family dinner and you know getting back
into dinner I've typically got you know
the blue light blocking glasses on again
to start to you know suppress any
exposure to to you know large amounts of
blue light I what else do I do
how long you a hatful with the with the
blue light looking-glass is 90 minutes -
I was before bed
yeah it's usually about 90 minutes two
hours before bed unless I plant like you
know whatever if my wife and I want to
have like you know like a you know a a
really intensive sex session or
something you know we're Plan B and up
till 10:30 or 11:00 you know talk and
having sex stuff like that like
sometimes I'll just like purposefully
not do a lot to wine myself but uh but
yeah I also I tend to have a pretty
raging appetite even after dinner so
I'll typically do something with glycine
or gelatin
which really just so I make jello I make
jello with just like some some gelatin
that'll mix with coconut milk and little
stevia sometimes they'll put a prebiotic
fiber in there which also helps with
sleep
I like acacia Fiber and then I'll just
put that in a food dehydrator for about
a day and you know stir that up keep
that in the fridge and I'll just give
myself a nice kind of like you know like
like a two inch by two inch piece of
jello
at night sometimes they'll put a little
bit of almond butter on that a little
touch of sea salt and that's like that's
my go-to dessert for keeping my appetite
station station yeah yeah it's because I
think that gelatin the glycine just
helps me go to go to bed and not feel
hungry later on so I'll have that
typically for dessert after dinner and
and then for the wind-down routine other
than that what else do I do I'm my my
go-to supplements for sleep or CBD I do
about typically high dose CBD most of
the research on CBD that shows that it
enhances sleep uses a lot more than than
what they use for like the angio lytic
effects usually it's anywhere from 100
to 600 milligrams for sleep so typically
I'll take about 100 milligrams of CBD
Sablan yep yep I like the droppers I
find out respond best of that just hold
it in mouth for a couple of minutes and
then like I mentioned that a little bit
of glycine with gelatin and then also
like I mentioned magnesium so CBD
magnesium and then a little bit of a gel
oh that's that's kind of like my go-to
snack lets you and I will see magnesium
supplement I'm using right now mag srt
by jigsaw health it's uh I think it's
Glisan 8 3 and 8 and citrate I think you
what sausage I it's about 400 okay
yeah so you just go to go to bowel
tolerance and then when you when you mix
that with having the vitamin C in the
baking soda in the morning it's great
for the bowels as well and then the red
light and then what I sleep on is I have
a gravity blanket you know a big I'm a
big fan of in addition to making sure
you sleep in a cold environment and your
pay attention to light
you're paying attention to not having a
lot of ambient noise in the bedroom
I think safety is big so I don't work in
bad an era I'm a laptop in bed
I don't even keep business books or
health and fitness books or anything
like that up in the bedroom it's all
just like fiction or something not
related to work and then I also find
when I pull like one of these big
breathable 25-pound gravity blankets
over myself for sleep it kind of
amplifies that feeling of safety even
more so it just it's it's SuperDuper
relaxing for me so I sleep with a
gravity blanket on top and one of those
chilly pad devices underneath because
the chilly pad will circulate about 55
degree cold water under my body while
I'm sleeping
which really enhances your sleep cycles
quite a bit and then I've got an
essential oil diffuser account like in
my office I'll diffuse uplifting scents
like you know peppermint rosemary etc in
the bedroom which is are like lavender
or bergen bajo or some really relaxing
scent that I'll defuse a while I'm
asleep
and then same thing I'll put on sleep
sleep blocking mask some foam earplugs I
have an app called sleep stream on my
phone and there's a lot of research
showing that uh you know there's all
these different noises that can block
out sound like white noise or brown
noise it turns out that pink noise is
the one that enhances your sleep the
most so I put some pink noise on that
and then let me think of there's
anything else how are you doing that
well Keith looks in well I got the foam
earplugs in but then the the the phones
and airplane mode next to the bed with
the sleep string wrap on just playing
pink noise just now have your phone
speaker yeah yeah because we have you
know we have like roosters and owls and
all sorts of stuff out here in the
forest so I just like to cover up that
that ambient noise and then I use breath
work to just kind of low myself to sleep
typically four count in seven count hold
eight count out and I'll do that for
about five or ten minutes and I'll just
you know doze off at that point just
kind of breathing myself to sleep
definitely one of the things that I like
about your day and the way that it's
constructed is that everything has its
place the
you're not half into anything apart from
perhaps doing little bits of extra
training while you work but the focus
there is in facilitating work not in
doing work while you train right I
particularly like the idea of the family
time the focused family time I know that
Ben Bergeron from chasing excellence big
fan of this and a Joe Rogan big fan of
this as well you know spending time with
your family where it's not half looking
at your kids half looking at your phone
half thinking about work still as the
emails to do this that and the other I
like the idea that you've got your
sections in the day that focus you
toward what you're supposed to do yeah
yeah yeah I think that a multitasking
you know in the sense of like rolling
golf balls under your feet or flipping a
pen while you're working is just fine
but multitasking as far as not being
focused and mindful in the task at hand
is just it's a huge issue these days and
so yeah I agree
full-on unbelievable look Ben man it's
been absolutely fantastic
your new book boundless linked in the
show notes below where else should
people go to to check out what you do
you know my podcasts all the articles
they put out you know all that jazz it's
just all at Ben Greenfield fitness calm
and then my my supplements company is
kyon ki o n and that's it get keen on
comm unbelievable everything will be
linked in the show notes below it's been
mind-blowing today so I'm sure there's a
lot of people that are going to go back
and listen to this if you enjoyed it
make sure to hit the subscribe button go
and check out Ben's podcast if you
enjoyed what we went through today then
he does deep dives on there all the time
Ben man thank you so much for your time
it's been awesome oh thanks man they
surround me up
[Music]